Attorney General Jeff Sessions is not
answering questions about a Justice
Department investigation at Harvard
University CBS News learned earlier this
month that the DOJ is investigating the
role of race in the admission process to
see if asian-american applicants are
held to a higher standard Paula Reid
asks the Attorney General about the
investigation and she got the silent
treatment big time she's outside Justice
Department headquarters in Washington
with more on this story Paula good
morning I saw that news conference
yesterday that was a very interesting
thing to watch but I have to say you did
not back down that's right you can't
back down the Justice Department hasn't
really opened many civil rights
investigations since Jeff sessions took
over but it has launched this probe into
Harvard University's affirmative action
practices while at the same time halting
most other forms of discrimination
investigation this is this is the
Attorney General the United States I
understand you're doing your job but I'm
doing mine too off-camera the Attorney
General's communications team blocked
questions about the Harvard case your
Civil Rights Division is investigating
Harvard University for possible civil
rights violations related to affirmative
action possibly discriminate against
asian-americans and white students why
is this a priority for your Justice
Department he was able to ask about
Alabama he was able to ask about
sanctuary cities why can't I ask about
this letters obtained by CBS News show
the Justice Department's Civil Rights
Division has concluded that the elite
school is out of compliance with the law
they also show that Harvard has refused
to hand over documents and has
challenged the department's authority to
investigate the Justice Department's
investigation is unprecedented
Vanita Gupta led the Civil Rights
Division at the Department of Justice
under President Obama the Justice
Department has never been a party in
these cases directly investigating an
institution we simply cannot allocate
our resources based on the color of
one's skin Attorney General Sessions has
been critical of affirmative action and
in 2015 then candidate Trump hinted it
might be time to end the practice I'm
fine with it we have it it's there but
it's coming to a time
maybe we don't need it 65% of Americans
believe race should not be used in
admissions decisions despite a lot of
these programs that blacks and Hispanics
are underrepresented in colleges and
universities today even more so than
they were in 1980 the Supreme Court has
upheld the use of race in admissions as
recently as 2016 what is the legal
argument that the Justice Department is
trying to pursue with this investigation
well the Justice Department clearly
seems to be trying to t if I get another
case for the Supreme Court it looks like
right now that they are looking for a
sympathetic attractive group of
plaintiffs here at the asian-american
students who've been denied admission at
Harvard and to try to drive a wedge
among communities of color by kind of
pitting asian-americans against
african-american and Hispanic students
the school says that it is trying to
give the government the documents it is
requested while also protecting student
privacy the Justice Department has given
Harvard until Friday to cooperate or it
could file a lawsuit Norah a really
important story Paula thank you for
reporting on this